okay sally the cat in her last days of
life
snuggling in close for comfort she fell
ill quickly with a mysterious disease
her owner beverly hanley believes it's
down to the pet food
she changed it at christmas five months
later
sally was dead she looked very glazed
it was almost like she was looking
through us and my first
thought was maybe she had a stroke
and um she had a very foggy expression
on her face
and she felt very very hot i was holding
on my arms
she had several seizures um she
defecated herself as well she's wet
herself and myself
and it didn't seem right at all
but the heartache isn't over beverly's
cat byron is now ill
after eating the same food as sally
her other cat didn't touch it and is
fine
at least 330 cats in the uk have died
from this rare
illness called feline pancetta
vets say it's important to watch out for
signs it could be things like loss of
appetite
vomiting weight loss lethargy
when it gets more severe you can see
bleeding from the the mouth
and sometimes bleeding in the feces so
if you notice
any changes with your cat particularly
vague signs
initially it's sort of this lethargy
loss of appetite
do give your vets a call straight away
particularly if you've been feeding this
food and you find it on that list
an investigation into the causes of the
cat deaths continues
the potential link to the pet food this
has been recalled from shelves as a
precaution
the manufacturer fold hill food said
assisting the food standards agency
investigation is an absolute priority
for the business
there are a number of tests on food
samples and ingredients
being conducted by independent
laboratories
there's no definitive evidence to
confirm a link at this stage between the
cat food products
and feline panda sepenia it's too late
to save sally but beverly wants answers
to why
she died and hopefully in time to save
her other cat from the same fate
charlotte lomas sky news